more signs of normality making headlines
in the valley tonight thanks for joining
us at 11 i'm denise valdez and i'm brian
loftis metro welcoming the public
back to first tuesday madison kimbrough
was there joining us live in madison
how was it in person
denise and brian people who live in the
spring valley area
were all ears tonight at their first
first tuesday
in quite some time i need protection in
our neighborhood
there's several ladies alone and the
crime is increasing cars are being
stolen elsewhere
car theft is up across the valley in
particular the spring valley area
i had neighbors calling me saying hey
there's a guy walking down the street
checking door handles on your car last
night today metro held its first
in-person first tuesday event since the
pandemic
it's designed to bring residents and
officers together to raise awareness on
subjects that directly impact the
community
metro says currently in the spring
valley area violent crimes are down
but other numbers are up currently we're
up in burglaries
both residential and commercial another
hot spot within the spring valley area
command is the west tropicana corridor
between i-15 and decatur and it hasn't
slipped metro's mind
so starting in january we've really put
a new focus on
how we police that area and for a long
time been a haven for street level
prostitution and
other crimes of quality of life overall
spring valley residents were happy to
have their in-person
sessions back and metro was pleased to
reconnect with the community
face to face again it's good to know
that they are out there and that they do
listen
and first tuesday is the first tuesday
of every month and if you're interested
in participating
you can go to metro's website to see
where your area of command is that is
open to the public reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now